what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i'm back at it again with a
new demonstrator video i said i'd cover
upper moon to doma if we got 6500 likes
on the upper moon one kokushibo video
and as i'm writing this this video has
over 17 000 likes in nine days i did not
expect that video to do so well so soon
so thank you to everyone who showed that
one so much love i think with the
entertainment district arc it's fitting
to do upper moon 6 next so if we get 7
000 likes on this one then i'll get
started on that one asap if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates also
shout out to itaikuji an online retailer
in japan that makes anime merch that is
normally exclusive to japan available to
fans all over the world they have a wide
selection of awesome anime merch
straight from japan including an entire
section on demonstrator which has some
of the best demonstrator figurines i've
ever seen along with a bunch of other
awesome stuff check them out link to
that is in the description and because
we're partnered with them you can now
use the coupon code anime uproar 500 for
an instant discount every time you use
the coupon code you're not only getting
awesome merch but directly supporting
this channel so check them out link to
that is in the description and now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all it's not an
overstatement when i say that upper moon
2 doma is probably the most hated and
hateable character in the entire series
and we're about to see why over the
course of this video not only is he one
of the strongest demons we know of he's
also a cult leader in his spare time and
he happens to be tied to so many other
important characters in the series in
one way or another my favorite fight in
the series also includes him so
considering all this i am very excited
to finally be covering him his first
appearance is actually in a flashback of
upper moon 6. as gootaro is hugging his
dying sister he wonders why no humans
ever help why it seems like all he gets
is bad luck after bad luck and then it's
doma who shows up and actually calls him
a poor thing and asks what's wrong dolma
is introduced as a messed up person he's
smiling as he's holding severed body
parts of one of his victims yet he
offers to solve yutaro's problems he
says he'll give them both blood saving
his sister from death and then ask the
master aka muzon if they can both be
demons it's not surprising that when he
asks them if they want to be demons
guterro agrees it's a way for him to
save his little sister the person he
cares about the most and so dolma is not
only upper moon too he also is
responsible for helping to create upper
moon 6. immediately he comes off as a
very powerful dude in contrast to
gyutaro here he comes off as a kind of
savior to him which goes with the whole
cult leader thing we next see him in the
present during chapter 98 when we get
the upper moon meet up after the defeat
of gyutero and daki doma is so annoying
that even a fellow upper moon a lower
ranking upper moon attacks him and tells
him to get lost doma proves to be even
more annoying because he's not even
bothered by akazel's behavior in fact he
says he doesn't mind at all and he
purposely didn't dodge because it's just
the way he and akasa play around the
funny thing is that akasa hates him but
dolma always has such a positive spin on
everything when upper moon 1 explains
that akaza shouldn't do that because it
disrupts the hierarchy and he should
request blood combat if he wishes to
fight doma doma responds that it would
be pointless because akasa couldn't beat
them he goes on to say akasa became a
demon before doma but doma rose more
quickly through the ranks doma actually
defends and patronizes the demon who
attacked him but it's important to note
that akazo was strong enough to beat
rengoku one of the strongest hashira and
doma is ranked higher than him and even
rose quicker through the ranks that's a
huge deal right away he's set up as an
annoying but extremely powerful demon
who doesn't seem to worry about anything
the fact that he doesn't take anything
personally could even be considered a
positive trait in a moral person but
this indifference extends to being
completely unbothered by doing brutal
and terrible things he can commit the
worst acts known to man and smiles if
nothing happened no conscience for this
dude at all and that's part of why he's
so hateable he's like the perfect
killing machine but more on that later
we then briefly see him put on his
called hat and ask for his believers to
be shown in and that's our first real
impression of dolma a constantly smiling
insanely powerful cult leader who even
annoys fellow upper moons in a data book
it's even said that muzon never really
liked him despite doma's loyalty to him
but liked or disliked doma was clearly
too powerful not to use now let's fast
forward to my favorite fight in the
series the battle with doma we find out
that kanae shinobu's older sister and
the former flower hashira was killed by
upper moon to doma himself shinobu emily
recognized him from kana's description
of a demon who looked like blood had
been dumped over his head shinobu also
recalls that kanae said the demon grins
and laughs and speaks calmly and kindly
honestly doma is a good character foil
for shinobu who is similar in her calm
and superficially polite ways even when
she's insulting giu for example the
difference is that we know deep down
shinobu feels things and is good at her
core but with dolma it feels like this
superficial layer is all there is
shinobu tries to save one of doma's
hostages from him and it looks like she
succeeds but then suddenly the damage
appears clearly doma was even faster
than she thought he takes out a pair of
sharp fans his weapon of choice he tells
us that he's the founder of the eternal
paradise faith where his role is to be
happy with all the faithful pretty much
according to him he's supposedly happy
all the time and he absorbs his women
believers and they become part of him
and thus part of the eternal happiness
he has a twisted philosophy that he's
saving his victims by freeing them from
fear and suffering you definitely have
some aspects of buddhist philosophy
being twisted by doma to serve his own
messed up faith and we'll see that
reflected when we get to his blood demon
art as well shinobu finally loses it and
unleashes all the rage she's been
holding back throughout the series you
could see it in her popping veins i love
me a good revenge fight and that's
exactly what this is for shinobu doma is
his usual patronizing self he's clearly
not in trouble and remains calm while
praising the person attacking him he
comments on shinobu's amazing thrust and
calls her very fast shinobu notices his
blood demon art when she realizes the
air around him is so cold she feels like
her lungs will burst shinobu as we know
is not physically strong enough to cut
off a demon's head so she uses poison
poison stronger than the poison used on
rui's mountain that works perfectly
against those weaker demons doma though
is able to break it down and recovers as
if he wasn't poisoned in the first place
he's also skilled enough to notice that
when she sheathes her sword the sound is
peculiar
so that must be where the compound
changes for her poison attacks shinobu
is fighting the most important fight of
her life and in contrast doma is still
smiling and saying stuff like this is
fun the mangaka has done a great job of
making it so that we really want to see
the smile wipe from his face once and
for all we then get dolma's backstory he
was said to be kind and clever from a
young age his mission according to him
was to help people in need and make them
happy he also had very unique eyes
rainbow colored and for the adults his
hair color was proof of his innocence
and specialness his parents apparently
created the paradise faith religion doma
felt sorry for them and played along
even though he never heard god's voice
as they thought he did at first it was
awkward for him when people worshipped
him and prayed to him he listened to the
stories of how people were suffering and
in pain and wanted paradise and he was
bored but he also cried thinking about
how sad it is that paradise is a human
created fairy tale and doesn't exist
unlike him they couldn't accept the fact
that there was nothing after death and
he pitied them for being so dumb he
wanted to make the pitiful people happy
and help them and he felt that that is
why he was born we see him smiling as
he's combing the hair of a skull
implying that he helped people by
killing them very messed up stuff dolma
is like an over-the-top example of what
you get when you spoil a kid from a
young age they put him on a pedestal
worshiped him as a god and eventually he
decided he knew what was the best
solution for humans even if the humans
were against it there isn't the same
humanizing factor in his backstory as
there is in akazas and kokushibos
because doma just comes off as always
having been patronizing and unbothered
by his horrible actions and that's fine
you don't need to sympathize with every
villain some can just be used for
carrying out a very satisfying revenge
story a revenge story that would be less
satisfying if dolma had been more
humanized back to the battle and
shinobu's poison attacks are getting
less and less effective doma even asks
if shinobu is all right because she's
sweating a lot and seems to be having
trouble breathing shinobu thinks to
herself that doma speed in building
resistance to her poisons is abnormal
doma explains that because of his blood
demon art breathing itself is dangerous
for his opponents he freezes their blood
turns it to mist and then scatters it
with his fan in a prolonged battle his
opponent's lungs are dying and through
the already mentioned method he sucks
blood even though he hasn't gotten
serious yet shinobu is in really bad
shape that is the power of upper moon 2.
even as doma remarks that shinobu may be
the fastest hashirah he's met yet he
ends up cutting her without her even
noticing so even though he's
complimenting her he's really
complimenting himself for being so much
faster than the fastest hashira he goes
on to insult her for being small and too
weak to cut off a demon head something
that shinobu has thought about a lot she
wished her hands weren't so small that
she was taller then she might have been
able to take his head after all dolma
does say that she might have beaten him
if she could cut off his head because
she's so fast but it's important to keep
in mind that as we'll see doma still
hasn't used many of his strongest
techniques and this is probably also a
statement that is designed to mess with
shinobu as well and make her unravel
mentally while she is losing physically
as well dolma is like the expert at
pushing buttons shinobu recalls how
kanai was going to say in the past that
perhaps she meaning shinobu would lose
to that demon aka doma if she fought him
but she stopped herself she definitely
didn't want chinobu to fight him but she
knew she probably couldn't stop shinobu
so she didn't want to say any more on
that matter in the present doma has done
massive damage and made shinobu doubt
herself to the point of tears kana's
spirit must come in and tell her to pull
herself together at first chinobu thinks
she lost so much blood she can't stand
and her left lung is punctured so she
can't breathe but kanae says it doesn't
matter notably against most people domo
would have already won just as he won
against the flower hashiram however
kane's speech to shinobu does a trick
she tells her that she decided to win so
she must win whatever the cost that's
the promise she made with kano she tells
her to do her best doma as darkly
hilarious as ever approaches shinobu
apologizing he says his cut wasn't
thorough enough so she's still suffering
as if he's really concerned about
shinobu's well-being shinobu with kane's
spirit's motivation manages to get up to
doma's surprise he even looks concerned
when he thinks about the pain of
shinobu's blood gurgling in her lungs
and how it must be beyond imagining he
has this concerned patronizing tone
throughout which just makes you hate him
more than if he acted like a jerk the
entire time shinobu prepares for one
last ditch effort and decides to aim for
doma's neck and although i don't think
doma is being 100 serious because he
underestimates shinobu it is still
awesome that shinobu manages to outspeed
him with the hundred-legged zigzag move
he can't predict her attack and shinobu
manages to pin doma by the neck to the
ceiling with her sword for a second it
looks like this may have been effective
against doma but that doesn't last long
his smile returns soon enough as shinobu
thinks to herself why doesn't poison
work against this guy doma being the
messed up dude he is cries and calls
shinobu's struggle so admirable he's so
impressed that such a weak girl is doing
so much it's the classic backhanded
compliment he's so well known for he
ends up deciding that shinobu is worth
eating and absorbs her as kanel is
coming in so dolma not only handled kane
but now shinobu too without any real
trouble when kanel says shinobu was her
big sister doma shows he's skilled
enough to notice that there doesn't seem
to be any blood relation judging from
the characteristics of the meat to use
his own words he also reveals that he
ate a lot of women because they are very
nutritious he even thinks the reason
akaza must have lost is because he never
ate females as doma starts crying for
his so-called best friend akaza kanel
tells him to knock it off she knows it's
lies because kanai found out he doesn't
feel anything and she felt sorry for him
that clearly gets to doma because for
once someone pitied him rather than the
other way around kanel goes on to call
his heart empty and him an empty shell
it's a side of kano we're not used to
seeing but it's clearly getting to dolma
because he stops smiling he drops the
act she's clearly picked up on one of
his insecurities and is probably hoping
it will affect his fighting by clouding
his mind kano actually succeeds in
dodging doma's first attack and doma
responds that she's reacting faster and
adapting to his moves and fighting style
she also isn't inhaling the powder
freeze scattered by his fan he says at
this point that she might be a little
more skillful than the hashra girl he
just ate meaning shinobu which is a
pretty crazy statement since it teases
the fact that kano is at least hasha
level and probably an even stronger
fighter than shinobu at this point
dolma's blood demon art is so powerful
that if kanel doesn't send strength all
the way to her fingertips her body
immediately starts trembling she says
she can only stand up to him because of
the fierce anger she feels that makes it
like her body is burning doma goes on to
hype up kano's abilities which in turn
hypes up the fact that he is doing so
well against her he says she has special
eyes she's predicting his movements and
she's straight up doing stuff that the
average swordsman can't do he knows he
needs to go for her eyes but he misses
he goes on to call her body well trained
and launches a freezing cloud attack
that would have frozen her eyeballs if
she didn't blink at the perfect time he
goes on to use a broad area ice
technique so that khanna thinks about
how she can't even get close that's a
very powerful ability for a demon
because swordsmen have to get close to
kill demons at least in this dimension
where there is no sun doma then forms a
wintry icicle's attack above kannau and
then lets them rain down on her she
barely avoids them and dolma all the
while is smiling and seems to be having
a good time he teases her saying that
she should stop backing off since she
can't cut off his head if she doesn't
get closer doma then unleashes some
insane speed even takano specialized it
looks like he straight up disappears not
only that doma is fast enough to take
her sword from her before she even
realized what was happening he creates a
game for himself where she has to come
and get it fortunately inosuke comes
into the scene at this point to help the
obviously losing kano he uses his
hilariously named move crazy cutting to
help deflect doma's attack so doma just
beat a hashira is fighting someone he
said was more skilled than that hashira
and now another skilled fighter joins
the scene inosuke even says that when
they defeat doma he'll become the beast
or bore hashira and spoilers since they
do win you can potentially argue that
they are both hasha level after the
battle but i'm getting ahead of myself
back to the battle itself it's so
interesting seeing how serious inosuke
becomes when he figures out that doma
absorbed shinobu he really liked shinobu
and seems to recall how she helped heal
him and how they even shared a pinky
promise inosuke goes on to do the
amazing thing of actually grabbing
kano's blade back without doma noticing
dome is too busy being impressed by
inosuke's weirdness and impressive
flexibility he calls him quick too
inosuke then slices doma's eyes because
dolma miscalculated his range not
accounting for his ability to dislocate
his body parts in order to extend his
reach this is a new attack of inosukes
and he was aiming for the neck but
missed inosuke immediately establishes
himself as a worthy fighter and partner
of hashin our level kanau here but the
inosuke flexing is short-lived when
dolma grabs inosuke's mask while the
latter is in mid-sentence it's very
similar to the time he grabbed kano's
sword suddenly and again shows his
impressive speed doma goes on to fill in
the blanks of inosuke's backstory for us
he speaks of a woman 17 or 18 who came
to him holding a baby this baby was
inosuke she came from an abusive
relationship she came to dolma because
she had nowhere else to go she had
inosuke's face when inosuke tries to say
that he was raised by boars and has no
human parents doma asks who gave him his
name he points out the fact that abhor
couldn't give birth to him when inosuke
tries to attack and shut up doma doma
injures him and kanaa has to save him
doma insists on finishing his story and
you know you're winning when you can
force your opponents to listen to a long
story mid-fight interestingly enough
doma says he didn't intend to eat
inosuke's mom he liked having someone so
pure by his side he said she was a fool
but had a beautiful singing voice she
sang about pinky promises to babynosuke
and dinosuke realizes that it wasn't
with shinobu that he had the pinky
promises he misremembered it was
actually with his mom somehow he
transposed his unconscious memory of his
mother onto shinobu which probably added
even more impact to her death to him
inosuke finally remembers the singing
and that's how he knows doma is right
she's saying that she'd protect him even
if it cost her her life and that's
pretty much what she would have to do
doma intended to keep her alive for her
whole lifespan but she found out he was
eating his believers as a result she ran
with enosuke and doma killed her doma
thought inosuke would die since his
mother dropped him from a cliff but
inosuke landed in the water and survived
she succeeded in saving him from one of
the strongest demons no small feat so
now out of nowhere this fight becomes
even more significant because now
inosuke is fighting against the demon
who killed his mom just as kano is
fighting against the demon who killed
her sisters inosuke in an epic moment
decides domo was right it was fate that
brought them together it was a miracle
because he'll now get to exact his
revenge however despite how strong kano
and ynosuke are at this point and i do
believe they are both hoshida level doma
flexes on them pretty hard when he says
he's out of time so he'll let them fight
a child of his he uses the move
crystalline divine child and creates an
ice doll the ice doll is very strong too
and is even able to unleash doma's blood
demon art it launches ice attacks and
keeps inos genkano busy as they think
about how a doll can have such power
doma says this doll can use techniques
almost as powerful as his own and he
says the rest is up to his doll it's
important to note that inosuke is
especially good at not inhaling doma's
blood demon art something that if one
were to inhale it would tear them apart
from the inside so if this was another
fighter less good at sensing the frozen
attacks he might have already fallen
however inosuke's sharply sensitive skin
makes him a really good fit for this
tricky upper moon as doma says he
immediately senses the slightest chill
in the air and thus can avoid serious
damage that would result from inhaling
the frozen air still doma's doll is
killing it as kano points out the ice
vines of the doll are pushing them both
back and dome is getting away then as if
things weren't getting bad enough doma
decides he'll create five more of these
ice clones what insane power one can
push kanao and inosuke back and yet he
can create at least five more which he
hopes will defeat the other
demonstrators in the castle as inosuke
is having trouble with the one ice clone
some significant slices appear on his
body kano though tells him not to panic
and that they just need to hang in a bit
more at first you're like how will more
time help them but then we see it as
dome is about to leave thinking that his
ice dolls will record the battle info
his face starts dissolving but let's
just take a second to appreciate how op
it is that he can gather info from these
dolls and then use it to be a better
fighter in future battles that's some
naruto training arc stuff right there
back to the dissolving face though and
it's made clear that this was the work
of shinobu the insect hashira but she
should also be called the poison hashira
we find out through a flashback that it
was the plan all along for shinobu to
get eaten by this demon absolutely crazy
stuff and it's definitely an aspect of
the fight that lends to it being one of
my favorite fights in all of demon
slayer i love that all of these
different revenge arcs reach their
climax here at once and shinobu being
willing to pay the ultimate price for
victory just makes it all the more
significant and legendary as we find out
shinobu knew doma loved eating females
and wouldn't be able to avoid eating a
female hashira with high physical
abilities and an excellent body let's
just appreciate the way she compliments
herself there for a second shinobu goes
on to reveal that she has a high
concentration of wisteria flower poison
circulating throughout her body kana
wanted to do it too but shinobu said it
would take more than a year of
constantly taking in wisteria flower
poison what's more it's never been done
before so they have no idea what the
side effects could be or if it would
even work on upper moons she reveals
that while she can only deliver 50
milligrams of poison with a sword if
she's eaten the dose of poison doma
would receive would be 37 kilograms
which is about 70 times the lethal
amount and finally that insanely lethal
amount finally kicks in dome so affected
that his ice clone which was pushing
kanoa ninosuke back on its own crumbles
this is their chance the poison weakened
him and now they have to cut his neck to
increase their chances of victory as
much as possible but instead of going
down without a fight dolma is still able
to unleash a giant ice buddha statue the
move is called water lily bodhisattva
and it towers over inosukan canal
placing some significant distance
between them and doma the two are
surprised to see that doma can launch
such a massive technique at this point
despite the fact that he's so poisoned
this technique is especially tricky
because it fills the broad area with
freezing air but if they fall back then
doma will have time to recover it seems
like an unwittable situation however
kano notices something with her special
eyes she can see that the technique is
rough and lacks precision it's a
technique of desperation a last-ditch
effort and it is time for her to use her
most powerful technique the ace up her
sleep now let's stop once more and take
note of this insane technique if doma
wasn't poisoned we can assume that it
wouldn't be a technique of desperation
but a practically invincible technique
the freezing air probably would have
been well distributed and getting close
to him would have meant breathing it in
and thus death he would have been
untouchable but because of shinobu's
efforts this technique was more of a
shaky shadow of what it could have been
rather than dom at his best kano then
uses her technique flower breathing
final form vermilion eye it's a
technique that puts such a big burden on
the eyes the eyes turn red and one can
lose their vision forever as well it's
definitely a big risk but when you think
about how shinobu sacrificed her whole
life it's obvious that kanel wouldn't
hesitate to use it this dangerous
technique raises dynamic vision to the
utmost making surrounding movements look
dull and slow again it's another case of
having the perfect character with the
perfect technique in the perfect place
at the perfect time most would not have
been able to avoid the freezing air and
ice statue attacks but with this ability
kana was able to make it to doma's
rotting head still even with her insane
skill and with her putting it all on the
line she almost doesn't succeed because
doma still manages to catch her with a
freezing attack before her sword
connects luckily inosuke throws his
swords at the right time and with the
right aim and his blades push hers
through doma's neck this fight is so
satisfying because it took all three of
what these characters had to barely come
out with the win unlike akazan mozan
doma doesn't get the option of regrowing
his head after it's cut off perhaps
because of the poison he doesn't have
the chance to evolve into the next level
demon that can only be killed by
sunlight and not by nichiren blades
dolma doesn't even feel afraid of dying
and he's not frustrated he lost like
throughout his whole existence human
emotions remain elusive like a dream to
him shinobu spirit tells him that now
she too can rest in peace and reveals
that tamayo helped them with the poison
too so it wasn't even just the three who
secured this seemingly impossible
victory although this victory was deeply
satisfying doma remains irritating to
the end and when you might wish he'd
feel bad and suffer finally for his
actions he just starts to believe that
he's falling in love with shinobu and
even blushes this is why we get some
people actually shipping dolma and
shinobu in the comments although i
really hope they're kidding but that is
it for doma it took all the knowledge
kane collected shinobu working with a
demon which she probably never thought
she'd do them creating an insanely
poisonous strategy by having shinobu
consumed wisteria flower poison for over
a year the life of shinobu kano's
ultimate technique and the cost of her
sight in one eye and in this case insane
and very unique breath style to pull it
off and even then with everything going
perfectly they just barely managed to
secure the victory because doma was just
that strong shinobu is the real star
here because if it wasn't for her
ultimate sacrifice and her knowledge of
poisons kano and ninosuke could not have
won that much was made clear we saw how
much trouble they were having with one
ice clone doma could create many more
including his giant ice statue that
makes him pretty much invincible because
in theory when launched not out of
desperation it will evenly fill the area
around him with freezing air making it
impossible for people to approach him
thanks to shinobu we never saw him at
full power but from what we saw we can
imagine how devastating it could have
been doma's power did not disappoint in
shonen you often like to see characters
go all out and still lose but with dolma
the mangaka couldn't allow it doma would
have clearly been too strong and had to
be nerfed by shinobu the argument can be
made that akaza briefly achieved the
next level demon form by regrowing his
head briefly and in that moment
surpassed doma before ultimately
deciding to self-destruct however since
aka's transformation didn't last and we
didn't see him fight full out with it
and since dolma might have transformed
too if not for the poison it's
reasonable to argue that doma earned his
number two spot among the upper moons
kukushibo is still stronger than him so
is muzon obviously but doma's blood
demon art is nothing to sneeze at and
i'd put it among the most tricky and
dangerous of all blood demon arts but
yeah that is it for this detailed video
about how strong upper moon 2 doma was
he was one of the strongest demons
arguably the most hated demon and
partook in my favorite fight in the
entire series as hateable as he is the
story was better with him in it and all
of his annoyingness and strength made it
that much more satisfying when against
all odds kanel and inosuke came out with
the win and completed the revenge that
shinobu and they too craved so badly if
you did enjoy this video and want to
keep the demonstrator videos coming you
know what to do channel the hasher
within and smash that like button with
no mercy remember smashing that like
button is yurichi energy and passing his
doma energy so choose wisely if we can
hit 7 000 i repeat 7 000 likes on this
one i'll get started on the upper moon 6
video asap if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates and
while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos on all the hashira demon
slayers demon moons and much more link
to that it's in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon here on youtube
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself alpha
sigma and kyle salisbury and other
one-tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata al jatal but they have
fun the red haired fox hinokami and
water the toasted chi corey mcgowan the
spike lonely the car dylan isadore
spidey light tennelle tungsten tarkis
baked buddhist jeremy cummings nga
whitley and our pro hero to your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks ryan garcia fat boy games
kydo might be a duck jessica rabbit
jeremy phillips alivenia temple king
matthew and demetrius water thank you
all so much if you do enjoy our work you
can support more of it by going over to
patreon.com anime uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing epic people right here and
you'll get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course thank meme so check
out patreon.com anime upload link in the
description if you're interested you can
also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
subscribe button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer and whichever way you support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
do
[Music]
you